a soap-opera breaks out at the White
House the Republicans decide that it's
time to spend all the monies and we
check the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
so many dramatic and terrible events all
in one day and we will discuss all of
them in just a moment but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over at
Indo Chino so you want to look stylish
you want to look good you want to look
like James Bond well the way to make
that happen is with the tailored suit
but you don't want to spend thousands of
dollars on his hailer suit you want to
go to my friends over at Indo Chino it's
the largest custom apparel company and
here is how it works you go to Indo
Chino comm you can pick your fabric
choose your customizations submit your
measurements place your order and you
wait for your custom suit it's custom
made just for you to arrive in 3 weeks
or less they make suits and shirts
designs your exact measurements for a
great fit and they have a wide selection
of high quality fabrics you can
personalize pretty much all the details
lapel jacket lining monogram much much
more they have offices in some major
cities there have one in Beverly Hills
that I went to when I got my Indo Chino
suit which is indeed the gaudiest and
flashiest
and most amazing suit that I own you can
shop online at ENSO Chino calm or visit
any of their showrooms across North
America and this week my listeners get
any premium Indo Chino suit for just 359
bucks at ENSO Chino calm when you enter
promo code
Shapiro's at checkout that's 50% off the
regular price for premium
made-to-measure suit again I mean you
know James Bond he goes to the what is
it Savoy row over at Savile Row over and
over in London well you don't have to do
any of that you can just go to Indo
Chino calm and the shipping is free Indo
Chino calm promo code Shapiro for any
premium suit for just 359 bucks plus
free shipping it's a best deal the best
deal you can find for a perfectly
tailored suit and you will look like a
million bucks so there's no better way
to do that for for a less expensive
price then Indo Chino comm enter promo
code Shapiro check out again for that
special deal 359 bucks for any premium
Indo Chino suit also that lets them know
that we sent you okay so the continuing
controversy that follows the white house
today is of course the controversy over
Rob Porter when did the White House know
the top Trump aide Rob Porter had
allegedly beaten not one but two of his
ex-wives and when did they know about it
what did they know about it and when do
they know about it right those are the
two questions
Shawn Kelley is the White House chief of
staff he's the one who stood by Porter
as late as Tuesday afternoon he was
saying the Rob Porter was his man he was
standing by Rob Porter Rob Porter was
just great they're a bunch of defenders
inside the Trump administration and it
now turns out that Trump is angry at
those defenders because there's a photo
of one of this guy's ex-wives and one of
this guy's ex-wives actually has a photo
of a big shiner on her face we showed it
to you yesterday well one of the big
questions that has arisen is there are
questions now about hope Hicks hope
Hicks is the beautiful young staffer who
works at the White House you very close
to the president you start off I believe
as a PR flack for Ivanka's fashion line
and then moved into the Trump campaign
and now is at the top levels of the
White House apparently very nice person
but has terrible taste in men and she is
now dating Rob Porter and Rob Porter's
ex-wife says listen hope if Rob hasn't
been abusive with you yet don't worry he
will reporters now in our relationship
with the White House press secretary
Hope Hicks do you think he's changed I
don't think he's changed does that worry
you
it worries me for a lot of reasons I
mean it definitely worries me because if
I'm being Frank with you if he hasn't
already been abusive with hope he will
and particularly now that he's under a
lot of stress and scrutiny that's that's
when the behaviors come out and if he
hasn't already he will so hope Hicks is
under a lot of fire from the White House
she's under a lot of fire from outside
the White House and for pretty good
reason here because what we have on our
hands here is indeed a soap opera yes
hope Hicks a young woman looking for
love in all the wrong places she dated
Corey Lewandowski the Trump campaign
manager who was married at the time
during the campaign was spotted yelling
at him on the street by the Nira post
Corey Lewandowski of course had a
penchant for grabbing women and bruising
them and then lying about it for three
weeks
hope Hicks then moved on from Corey
Lewandowski to rob Porter who it turns
out has a penchant for allegedly
punching women in the face kopecks then
helped co-write the memo and that memo
that would exonerate Brad Porter that
memo basically was written for Kelly and
said that Rob Porter was a wonderful man
so not only does hope Hicks have some
problems in choosing dudes hope excess
from Robins in defending that bad dudes
and president Trump is rightly angry
saying why in the world are you
defending a staffer over me your job is
to protect me from Bad staffers Trump
apparently didn't know about the
statement that had been drafted in order
to help exonerate Rob Porter he didn't
know about any of that stuff until it
came out it was too late for him to do
anything so he's spitting mad at hope
Hicks as well he should be so that is
the soap opera portion of the what's
going on at the White House we also have
the John Kelly portion of what's going
on at the White House so Kelly it now
turns out testified in 2016 on behalf of
a marine who is alleged to have
committed some sort of sexual abuse or
sexual assault and he went on to go
according to our times he was this
marine went on to abuse a child sexually
so there there's a lot of problems
inside the Trump administration with
defending some pretty bad folks Raj Shah
is out there defending the White House
response yesterday why was he out there
as opposed to hope X well because hope
is at the center of the of the soap
operas and is any of this good for the
White House the answer of course is no
but we've had a lot of bad staffing
decisions right in the first year of the
Trump administration we had Steve ban
a piece-of-crap was in and then he was
out we had Anthony scare Moochie who was
in it for five minutes and then out we
had Mike Flynn who's now under
indictment he was in and then he was out
we've had 37 people inside the Trump
administration who were in and then they
were out it not good so Raj Shah was out
there trying to explain this yesterday
because hope Hicks couldn't come front
and center and defend what she'd done
cuz she's involved with the man by the
way the Lewandowski the the other
elements the soap opera that I forgot
the other element is that Corey
Lewandowski allegedly
is one who leach to the media all of the
information about Rob Porter apparently
yeah we can play the music
that's right Corey Lewandowski the hope
picks his ex-boyfriend who was married
at the time was apparently suspected by
the White House of being the guy who
leaked out all the information about Rob
Porter in the first place so the
ex-boyfriend going after the current
boyfriend and the girlfriend of the
abusive boyfriend two ex-wives defending
that person instead of the president so
ok enough with soap opera ok so Raj Shah
defending the White House yesterday it
was not a particularly good look the
allegations made against Rob Porter as
we understand them involve incidents
long before he joined the White House
therefore they are best evaluated
through the background check process
it's important to remember that Rob
Porter has repeatedly denied these
allegations and done so publicly that
doesn't change how serious and
disturbing these allegations are ok the
problem is now a lot of people move
about this at the time the Washington
Post reporting today quote in January
2017 right is a year ago White House
Donna counseled on McGavin learned of
the allegations and he wanted to stay
put because he saw the Harvard Law Train
Capitol Hill veteran is a studying
professional voice in the White House
according to people familiar with the
matter his view didn't change in June
when the FBI flagged some of its
findings to the White House nor did he
act in September when he learned that
domestic violence claims were delaying
Porter's security clearance or in
November when Porter's former girlfriend
contacted him about the allegations
according to these people that's four
separate times in a year that the White
House Counsel was told that this guy was
a real problem and had some serious
issues in his past and the White House
Counsel did nothing about it
which raises some questions what exactly
is the White House looking for they're
looking for good staffers capable
staffers is the White House looking for
people who are good at their jobs
where's the White House looking for
loyalty because you look at Rao's
response to yesterday saying well the
process sort of had to play out and now
look at the white
response to Omarosa okay let's look at
the White House response to Omarosa so
uh morosely yesterday did two to go back
for a second Omarosa Manigault is a
person who is on trump's reality TV show
she was fired three times on a separate
reality TV shows then he hired her for
the campaign and then she was working in
the White House basically walking around
doing stuff that nobody knows what she
was doing and then she came out
yesterday and on TV she said that
everything in the White House is awful I
here's what she had to say
not there I don't it's not like it's not
my circus not my Luckies you know I'd
like to say not my problem but I can't
say that because oh it's so bad okay so
she says all this stuff on and people oh
my goodness the crying and yes Trump
picked this person to be in the White
House solid staffing picked by the
president she then came out and she said
that she would not vote for Trump again
if she were given the opportunity would
you vote for him okay
I'm billionaires okay so how did the
White House respond to that the White
House ripped the crap out of amaurosis
oh you have a guy in the White House
who's credibly accused by two ex-wives
of beating them and the White House
quasi defends until the last minute
Omarosa says that I won't vote for the
guy again she's a reality star was this
non predictable right and the way here
was the White House ripping on the rosa
she described the situation inside the
White House as bad and said it is not
going to be okay
not very seriously Omarosa was fired
three times on the apprentice and this
is the fourth time we let her go she had
limited contact with the president while
here
she has no contact now okay so I love
that they fired her three times when
they brought her back the fourth and
then they fired her fourth time but
they're really pissed at Omarosa but Rob
Porter you know that really dicey about
which demonstrates it when it comes to
the Trump administration loyalty matters
a lot more than competence and that's a
serious problem that should not be the
case at any business loyalty matters
competence matters more particularly the
level of the White House right people
who made one anti Trump remark during
the campaign have been banned
essentially from the White House or at
least were when they originally staffed
it up and that rules out a lot of pretty
competent people because they weren't
quote-unquote loyal and so you end up
with loyalists who may not in fact be
particularly competent there's a bunker
mentality at the White House and it came
to bear here and it's really nasty and
there is no excuse for it it is
disgusting that anyone was defending Rob
Porter after these allegations were
known it is particularly disgusting that
people were defending Rob Porter after
you know after there were reports on
Tuesday again all of that there's just
no excuse for it and you have to wonder
whether whether the people in charge who
knew about it ought to be fired and I am
talking about John Kelly if John Kelly
knew and he was defending this guy for a
year if McGann knew for a year front
they they've missed served the President
of the United States okay so I do want
to talk about a piece of even bigger
news that is the the Republicans
deciding that fiscal conservatism is no
longer a thing first I want to say thank
you to our sponsors over at blinds at
calm so there's one part of your house
you don't think about very much right
you think about the floors you think
about the walls you think about the
furniture but you don't very often think
about the window coverings and that's
something you should
be thinking about because window
coverings can make a huge difference in
the look and feel of your house they can
also save you on energy cost as well
taking the time to pick out blinds
however it sounds expensive kind of
boring installing them yourself sounds
like a giant pain in the butt but
blindness calm makes it really easy for
you if you're not sure what you want or
even where to start with blinds calm you
get a free online design consultation
you send them pictures of your house
they send back custom recommendations
from a professional from what will work
with your color scheme furniture
specific rooms they'll even send you
free samples to make sure everything
looks as good in person as it does
online every order gets free shipping
and this is the best part if you
accidentally miss measure or you pick
the wrong color if you screw up
blinds.com will remake your blinds for
free so you're the one at fault that
matter they will make it right anyway so
there's no reason for you to look like
you live in a derelict trailer instead
why don't you go out and get some decent
blinds for a limited time get 20% off of
everything at blinds calm when you use
promo code Ben that's blinds comp remote
code Ben again blind second promo code
Ben you get 20% off everything the faux
wood blinds the cellular shades the
roller shades and more blinds Comm promo
code Ben rules and restrictions do apply
go check it out use that promo code Ben
as well so they know that we sent you
all right so last night late in the
evening right in the early morning hours
on the East Coast the Republican
Congress along with a bunch of Democrats
voted in favor of a two-year funding
bill this is not a budget okay it's not
technically a budget the reason that
makes a difference is if you don't pass
a budget you can't use reconciliation
processes to pass new bills I discuss
this a little bit yesterday but in order
for you to pass a bill under
reconciliation meeting with 51 votes in
the Senate in order for the filibuster
not to apply you have to pass a bill
that is budget neutral well that doesn't
apply if there is no budget you cannot
have a budget neutral bill if there is
no budget so they essentially passed a
funding bill but no budget so that
prevents them from passing any new
legislation that really affects spending
so they can pass something on daca maybe
but that's about it right there will be
no further movement on Obamacare
there'll be no further movement on taxes
there will be no further movement
significant movement on regulation in
all likelihood you know that's a serious
problem the bigger problem however is
they just blew out the budget I mean
blew it out they they're spending more
money now than Barack Obama was spending
they're spending about the same amount
of money actually so Bob was saying
they've got a trillion dollar debt
yesterday a trillion dollar deficit in
the budget they blew a hole in it Rand
Paul wanted to stand up and say
something about it
yo Rand has a
knack for standing and talking at these
times and that's something you got to
appreciate about the senator from
Kentucky here is Rand Paul saying listen
you know we campaigned on fiscal
responsibility and then we lie about it
and you know the thing is is we think
when Democrats are in charge that the
Republicans of the conservative party
the problem is when the Republicans are
in charge
there's no conservative party and that's
kind of where we are now someone is to
stand up and say you should spend what
comes in we should balance our ledger
and that used to be what it meant to be
conservative but a lot of so-called
conservatives lose their mind once it
becomes a partisan thing and they say we
must govern now so they've governed by
giving is massive new debt and I don't
think that's good for the country I
think ultimately it threatens our
security not only our external security
but also the internal foundation of the
country is threatened but so so large a
debt he's exactly right here the real
problem with the debt is not that we're
gonna go bankrupt immediately we're
still the strongest economy on planet
earth that means people are gonna
continue buying our bonds but one of the
problems you have is that over time as
you accrue more and more debt we're
gonna keep getting people to buy into
that right now our the American debt to
GDP ratio is growing and growing so I
want to look it up right now the United
States American debt to GDP ratio let's
see what is it here in the United States
is let's see it is 106 point one percent
of the countries at GDP we have a
government debt equivalent to more than
the entire country GDP okay that is not
a good thing that is not a good thing
okay we've reached a record low in that
number in 1981 under Reagan when our
government debt was only 32 percent of
GDP but that is not a healthy number
okay if you look at debt to GDP ratio by
country we are we are starting to climb
those charts and they are not good in
the slightest right in Japan of course
Japan is basically bankrupt their public
debt is now 243 percent of GDP but
China's really looks like 23 percent of
GDP using just tax the crap out of their
own citizens but if you look at some of
the more healthy countries like Germany
they have a 70% GDP to debt ratio or
debt to GDP ratio even France ranks
below us the UK ranks below us we have
been selling our debt at ridiculous
rates for a long time and eventually
that's gonna come around to buy II can't
just borrow on the credit card
interminably in the end somebody's going
to stop lending you that line of credit
when that happens they're going to have
to be austerity measures nobody wants to
look at that however because they're
afraid of the political blowback should
that happen Rand Paul suggests that it
is hypocrisy for Republicans who talk
deficit for years and years and years
and then under Obama and then Trump
becomes president suddenly we stop
talking deficit anymore
how government's taking off and this new
stimulus of deficit spending will be as
big as President Obama stimulus don't
you remember when Republicans how to
high heaven that President Obama was
spending us into the gutter spending us
into oblivion and now Republicans are
doing the same thing and so I ask the
question whose fault is it Republicans
yes whose fault is it Democrats yes it's
both parties fault you realize that this
is the secret of Washington the dirty
little secret is the Republicans are
loudly clamoring for more military
spending but they can't get it unless
they give the Democrats welfare spending
so they raise all the spending it's a
compromise in the wrong direction okay
and he is he is correct about this he is
wrong by the way about military spending
as a general matter this is one of the
problems with Rand Paul's that Rand is
very anti military spending I'm fine
with the idea that we don't have to
radically revamp our military spending
and jet and it upward in any in
any tremendous way but Rand action wants
to cut it tremendously because he thinks
that we should just bring our troops
home from Afghanistan for example which
is quasi delusional but when he talks
about the fact that Republicans have
ceased to care about the budget he's a
hundred percent correct here's what is
in this bill okay according to ABC News
two-year budget deal would lift caps on
defense and non-defense spending by
three hundred billion dollars over two
years it includes six billion - phylla
to fight the opioid crisis five point
eight billion for child care Development
Block Grants four billion for veterans
medical facilities two billion for
medical research 20 billion to augment
existing infrastructure programs four
billion for college affordability is
College gonna get more affordable no
it's not gonna get more affordable the
measure would extend government funding
at current levels until March 23rd to
allow lawmakers to finalize details on
the spending in a separate measure
lawmakers would also raise the nation's
debt limit into 2019
so we'll have no more government
shutdowns until past the congressional
elections which was part of the goal
here
she has chod hot air is fulminating over
this he says listen everyone who is
fighting for conservative principles
okay this means that you no longer get
to talk about fiscal conservatives in
the future you can't talk about fiscal
conservatism about fiscal responsibility
when you're blowing out budgets to the
tune of trillion-dollar deficits with an
entirely Republican Congress by the way
they told me if I didn't vote for Trump
we get trillion-dollar deficits and daca
and apparently they were right I mean
this is pretty amazing stuff and they're
a bunch of fiscal conservatives of days
past you voted for this thing right
Speaker of the House Paul Ryan senator
Ted Cruz right both of these people
voted for the new budget Cruz said he
had to for the disaster funding most of
the disaster funding already taken place
it's like 51 billion dollars of disaster
funding had already been funded this
adds a bunch of boondoggle on top of it
Paul Ryan was interested in raising the
the military spending okay well then get
your own people in line sir then get
your Republicans in line
there are 16 Republicans who didn't vote
for it including Rand Paul and Mike Lee
right Michael Lee was really angry
because he said this process is
completely corrupt which it is the way
of propriate SAR supposed to be done are
not in the 700 page omnibus packages
that are rolled out at midnight and no
one reads that's not the way this is
supposed to be done Appropriations
packages are supposed to be done by
apartment and by Department the way it
was supposed to work is that if you have
a Department of Defense bill you of a
defense spending bill the defense
authorization bill they have a Health
and Human Services authorization bill
and you have a commerce authorization
bill then you have a Department of
Education authorization bill and then we
can debate what should be in and what
should be out of each one of those bills
the house by the way a hundred days ago
past 12 authorization bills for each of
the departments the Senate didn't move
on any of them
instead the Senate moves into the site
of the back room and they negotiate an
omnibus package and they said you get to
vote up or down that is not a way to be
fiscally responsible but Republicans
don't care about that anymore you know
why Republicans don't care here's the
dirty little secret there's our little
secret is that Trump's populism works
because politically speaking Trump is
recognizing a truth that fiscal
conservatives are gonna have to come to
grips with that is voters lie okay
voters say they want fiscal conservatism
voters say they want cuts voters say
they want the government to spend within
its limits but the minute you say to
voters
guys we're gonna have to restructure
Social Security voters balk and then
they voted Democrat in other words
we like to pretend the word of the child
who's capable of delayed gratification
there's a very famous delayed
gratification experiment where you can
actually tell IQ of children in a very
basic way through this experiment if you
take a four-year-old and you say to them
I'm gonna put this cookie in front of
you right now you can either eat that
cookie right now or if you wait three
minutes you will get a second cookie all
right you get two cookies kids who have
lower IQs tend to pick the cookie up and
eat it right away
kids with higher IQs tend to sit there
and wait for the second cookie okay well
we all like to pretend that we're the
kid with the second cookie there were
the higher IQ kids in reality we are not
we like to think of ourselves as smart
but we're dumb so when it comes to
action like we say yeah let's cut the
spending but the minute that it comes to
something we want then all of a sudden
we don't care about the spending anymore
and we're always saying it's an
emergency situation john cornyn and
yesterday he ripped into policy and I
know he wants to make a point he has
that right I agree with many of the
concerns about deficits and debt but we
are in an emergency situation when's the
last time we weren't in an emergency
situation when's the last time we
actually had a full-throated debate
about government spending and we weren't
in a quote/unquote emergency situation
not as far as I can recall last time I
remember is when Bush was president when
Obama was president then you know we had
significant debates over spending the
budgets that the Democratic Congress
passed were abysmal once Republicans get
in control for Congress has been
emergency measures all the way down
here's the problem if you're never
willing to shut down the government if
you're never willing to actually have
these hard-headed contacts if you're
never willing to actually have
conversations about what needs to stay
and what needs to go you're never going
to get to anything remotely approaching
fiscal responsibility just a disaster
and the fact that so many supposed
fiscal conservatives are looking the
other way on this demonstrates that some
of the tea party was a lie there are a
lot of people who are tea partiers who
were saying they wanted lower government
spending but they only wanted lower
government spending when they thought
Democrats were doing it the minute it's
Trump in charge and the Republicans in
charge they're willing to look the other
way because after all tax cuts and
defense spending and if we have to get
those things that I guess we can blow
out spending like it's like it's 2009
just ridiculous a ridiculous deal there
is no reason that Republican should have
signed off on it and it is a disgrace to
a Republican party that does it no
longer represents anything it no longer
represents anything that that means
anything when it comes to government
when it comes to smaller government or
go
limitations just terrible okay so in
just a second I'm gonna give you the
latest update on memo fights 2018 but
first I wanna say thank you to our
sponsors over at Dollar Shave Club so
you've heard me talk about the great
shave that I get with my dollar saved
Club razor right here below the chin
right here Elena especially when I use
it with my doctor she dr. Carver's had
shaved butter well I can tell you that
when you all remember you get much more
than that they make products for your
hair your face your skin shower
everything you need they have me looking
and feeling great look at me I didn't
even sleep last night I look like a
million bucks
that's Dollar Shave Club doing its work
and it's all their own original stuff
they use the finest premium ingredients
they deliver it to you just like they do
their razors this means no more annoying
trips to the store you don't have to
cruise up and down the aisles looking at
expensive products instead you can use
Dollar Shave Club for pretty much
everything razor razors body cleanser
hair gel and yes the fabled butt wipes
DSE has you covered head to toe you can
either use the budget or you can use
Dollar Shave Club butt wipes the butt
wipes are much more comfortable now is a
great time to give Dollar Shave Club a
try you get your first month of their
best razor along with travel sized
versions of shaved butter body cleanser
and yes even the magical mystical about
wipes for just $5 after that replacement
cartridges ship for just a few bucks a
month
it is the DSC starter set get yours for
just five bucks exclusively at
dollarshaveclub.com slash Ben that's
dollarshaveclub.com slash menus that
slash pence they know that these that we
sent you and again you get that special
deal you get the travel sized versions
of all of the magical things for just $5
and then the replacement cartridges ship
for just a few bucks a month in the DSC
starter set dollarshaveclub.com slash
been use that slash been against they
know that we say you okay so more on mo
52018 I know you're getting tired of it
I'm getting tired of it hurts my throat
you know a certain point you can only
say memo fight so many times before you
start to get a sore throat but there is
more information on memo fight okay so
Devin Nunez has essentially uncovered
there than the new memo that's going to
come out is going to cover the fact that
apparently Hillary State Department was
funneling information to Christopher
Steele via a few of Hillary Clinton's
special allies but basically Christopher
Steele was making a Trump dossier based
on Hillary sources providing the
information to the the John Kerry State
Department which was staffed by Hillary
holdovers and Hillary friends and they
were passing that information on to the
spy Christopher Steele to pass it on to
the
FBI right that's the chain of events
well now the guy who was in the middle
of that the guy at the State Department
got and Jonathan Winer he is writing
about this in the pages of the
Washington Post here's what he writes he
writes House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Devin Nunez announced last week
that the next phase of his investigation
of the events that led to the
appointment of special counsel Robert
Muller will focus on the State
Department his apparent area of interest
is my relationship with former British
intelligence professional Christopher
Steele and my role and materials still
ultimately shared with the FBI so he
says here's the real story in the 1990s
I was a senior official at the State
Department and he worked on Russian
matters after 1999 I left the State
Department developed a legal and
consulting problem practice that
involved Russian matters in 2009 I met
and became friends with Steele after he
retired from British government service
focusing on Russia Steele was providing
business intelligence on the same kind
of issues I worked on at the time
in 2013 I returned to the State
Department at the request of Secretary
of State John Kerry over the years
Steele and I had discussed many matters
relating to Russia he asked me whether
the State Department would like copies
of new information as he developed it
I contacted Victoria Nuland a career
diplomat and Hilary hack who's an
Assistant Secretary of State for
European and Eurasian affairs and shared
with her several of Steele's reports she
told me they were useful asked me to
continue to send them so in other words
Steele was providing the State
Department with information that had
nothing to do with Trump but did have to
do with Russia this is the guy's
contention in the summer of 2016
Steele told me he had learned of
disturbing information regarding
possible ties between Donald Trump his
campaign and senior Russian officials he
did not provide details but made clear
the information involved active measures
of Soviet intelligence term for
propaganda and related activities to
influence events in other countries in
September 2016 Steele that I met in
Washington and discussed the information
now known as the dossier Steele sources
suggested that the Kremlin not only had
been behind the hacking of the DNC and
the Hillary Clinton campaign but had
also compromised Trump and develop ties
with his associates in campaigns and now
Steele wasn't just blabbing to the FBI
he was blabbing to the State Department
which has no power to really do anything
in this matter the FBI presumably should
be the one telling the State Department
what it needs to know right it's their
job to do that it's not Christopher
Steele's job to do that he says he was
allowed to review but not to keep a copy
of these reports to enable me to alert
the State Department
I prepared a two-page summary and shared
it with Nuland who indicated that she
felt the Secretary of State needed to be
where it made aware of the material and
then here's where it gets good in late
September says in Jonathan Winer the
State Department hack I spoke with an
old friend Sidney Blumenthal
whom I met three
years ago when I was investing the
iran-contra affair right Sidney
Blumenthal is the lead Hillary axe
person in the Western world I mean he
was the dirty muckraker he went after
you remember the background in Clinton
administration Sidney Blumenthal sued
Matt Drudge there's a big deal while
talking about the hacking apparently all
right but then he got to talking about
the hacking and Blumenthal discussed
steals reports he showed Winer notes
gathered by a journalist I did not know
Cody Shearer another Blumenthal Hillary
hack that alleged the Russians had
compromising information on Trump of a
sexual and financial nature what struck
me was how some of the material echoed
steals but appeared to involve different
sources on my own I shared a copy of
these notes with Steele to ask for his
professional reaction he told me his
potentially collateral information I
asked what that meant them and then it
was confirmatory information so in other
words this guy at the State Department
was funneling information to steal now
here's the question let's say that he
knew there was that there was terrible
stuff going on why was he funneling it
to steal and not directly to the FBI
right he works for the government why
didn't Joe Nathan whiner just take the
information he was receiving from
Hillary's flax and forwarding that on to
the FBI as opposed to funneling it
through steel the answer is that he sent
it to steel because if he had sends it
directly from the State Department to
the FBI the FBI would have said where
did you get a Jonathan and he would have
had to say Sidney Blumenthal and the FBI
would have go on you got to be kidding
me we're not even taking a look at this
what does it be funneled into
Christopher steel steel could obscure
the source of the information and then
the FBI would take that for a FISA
warrant right that's the most plausible
possible explanation here so there is
something dirty going on maybe wine or
since I'm in no position to judge the
accuracy of the information generated by
steel or sure but as alarmed at Russia's
role in the 2016 election I believe all
Americans should be alarmed and United
in the search for truth but this wasn't
about the search for truth of the war
you would have provided it to the
government not to Christopher steel who
has at best an ancillary spy on Russian
issues so yeah and this is it this is a
serious problem that's not the only
serious problem apparently there's a
story out today people I think are
taking this a little bit too much I
think that I think they're reading too
much into this there's a story today out
from Edie Henry at Fox News he says that
Senator Mark Moore a top Democrat on the
Senate Intelligence Committee who've
been leading a congressional
investigation into president Trump's
alleged ties to Russia had extensive
contact last year with a lobbyist for
Russian oligarch who's offering Warner
access to former British spy and dossier
author Christopher Steele
the text messages obtained exclusively
by Fox News so Warner texted this
lobbyist who was in the pocket of the
Russians we have so much to discuss you
need to be careful but we can help our
country Walden says I'm in he had ties
to Hillary Clinton as well as to Russia
so that was not the extent of the of the
text according to the text exchanges
Warner seemed particularly intense I'm
connecting directly with Steel without
anyone else on the Senate Intelligence
Committee being in the loop at least
initially in one text to the lobbyist
Warner Road who'd rather not have a
paper trail of his messages an aides
Warner confirmed to fox news that the
messages were authentic the messages
were obtained by a Republican source
marked confidential and are not
classified they're turned over to the
Senate panel by Waldman last September
Waldman is best known for signing a
40,000 dollar monthly retainer in 2008
and 2009 to lobby the US government on
behalf of a controversial Russian
billionaire who's connected with the
Russian government so an aide to Richard
Burr who's the Republican chairman of
the Senate Intelligence Committee
he told Fox News that Burr was aware of
the contact Warner had made with
Steele's representatives he said I don't
believe he was aware of the content of
the text messages initially now Bert is
defending this okay sobre here's the
part where I say Republicans could read
too much into this so the way they could
read too much into this is by ignoring
the fact that Richard Burr says this
isn't a big deal so Morris text messages
were quietly given to the Intelligence
Committee after he and burr signed a
joint request for the messages last June
Warner and burr privately informed the
rest of the Democratic and Republican
senators on the panel of Warner's text
messages in a meeting last October a
Warner aide acknowledged that Warner and
Burr revealed the text to their
colleagues on the panel because quote
they realized out of context it doesn't
look great but aides to warn remember
both stressed the chairman was kept
apprised of Warner's effort so in other
words it looks like the Republicans knew
about these text messages that said you
know if they didn't you know and this is
where I say you can reach much into this
if they didn't then that would be
troublesome Marco Rubio suggesting that
it's not a big deal he tweeted out today
senator Warner fully disclosed this to
the committee four months ago has had
zero impact on our work the real
question is whether the Republicans were
being kept contemporaneously advised of
Mark Warner reaching out via Russian
sources - Christopher Steele if the
answer is yes if the Republicans were
aware then it's not a big deal if
however they were not aware then it
could theoretically be a big deal it
looked like the Democrats were fishing
for information from Christopher Steele
without knowledge of the Republicans
which is not a particularly great thing
okay so there's a little bit more here
here's another story as well that that
is I think troubling and this one is not
really about Trump it's more about
Hillary Clinton it's gotten dramatic
under play in the media I'm gonna get to
that in just a second but first you're
gonna have to go over to Daley wire calm
and subscribe for $9.99 a month you can
get a subscription to daily wire calm
when you do you get the rest of our show
live you get to be part of our mailbag
which we are doing today if you want to
ask a question to me right now we do
live questions subscribe now like I mean
now as you're watching this go and
subscribe when you subscribe you get not
only my show live you get the rest of
Michael Moses awful show live you get
the rest of the Andrew clavin's good
show live you get all of those at Plus
this Valentine's Day Wednesday February
14th and 5 p.m. Eastern the lonely and
desperate pathetic Michael moles will
literally be waiting for your questions
in his smoking jacket in our next
episode of the conversation Michaels
pathetic pleas for attention will stream
live on Facebook YouTube and the Daily
wire website everybody can watch for
free and watch him just make a fool of
himself but only subscribers can join
the website and help torture him to ask
questions as a subscriber log into our
website at daily wire.com head over to
the conversation page and that's where
you can watch the live stream after that
you start typing into the daily wear
chat box and Michael will answer live
questions as they come in for an entire
hour well presumably looking completely
pretentious and making references to
obscure Italian novels once again
subscribe to get your questions answered
by Knolls
this Valentine's Day Wednesday February
14th at 5 p.m. Eastern 2 p.m. Pacific
and join the conversation by the way
please do not watch for the sake of your
own eyeballs do not watch our promo for
this on Facebook our promo for the
Michael Noel's
Valentine's Day episode on Facebook is
supremely disturbing and I'm very
disappointed in Alicia Krauss for doing
the 900 number voice for that for that
voice over you can go check that out on
our Facebook page now if you just want
to watch the show late by the way sorry
if you want the annual subscription then
you get this the leftist tears hot or
cold tumblr I don't have to talk to you
but how great it is you know already
it's fantastic 99 bucks a year is
cheaper than our monthly subscription so
if you are wise you'll just go to the
annual if you want to listen later
iTunes SoundCloud stitcher make sure you
subscribe please leave us a review we
always appreciate it we are the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast in
the nation
all right so here is this final story
that you need to know about today in the
news roundup of scandal so an FBI
informant according to the hill
connected to the uranium one controversy
told three congressional committees in a
written statement that Russia routed
millions of dollars to America with the
expectation it would be used to benefit
Bill Clinton's charitable efforts
well Secretary of State Hillary Clinton
quarterbacked a reset in us-russian
relations the informants name is Douglas
Campbell he said in a statement obtained
by the hill that he was told by Russian
nuclear executives that Moscow had hired
the American lobbying firm a PCO
worldwide specifically because it was in
position to influence the Obama
administration and more specifically
Hillary Clinton Democrats have cast
doubt on Campbell's credibility so
they're gonna have a big battle over all
of this so again it sounds like there's
more to the Iranian one scandal than the
media were willing to cover or let on
early on we will follow that as it as it
continues okay so time for a couple
things I like then a couple things I
hate and will mailbag it up so things I
like so today there's a good book out by
Douglas Murray it's called the strange
death of Europe it talks all about in a
not unsympathetic way the problems with
mass migration into Europe particularly
Islamic mass migration into Europe
failures of assimilation inside Europe
and how this is posing threats the
future of the of the continent and
Western civilization as a whole it is
well worth the read it is sobering for
sure check it out Douglas Murray's the
strange death of Europe okay so a couple
of things that I hate so thing that I
hate number one all right thing that I
hate number one so on Siena and Alison
Camerata had on a Nazi why did she have
on a Nazi because this Nazi won a GOP
primary in Illinois
now this schmuck wins a primary in
Illinois every couple of years and the
Republicans will refuse to sponsor him
and throw him off the ballot that's
gonna happen again this year but since
the media are fully informed that they
are the since the media are fully
cognizant that they are trying to turn
Republicans into Nazis it behooves them
to find any Nazi who calls himself
Republican and put them on TV they would
never put Louis Farrakhan on TV or any
member of the Congressional Black Caucus
and ask them about Louis Farrakhan but
they will do this with the subscribe for
militant that said it does demonstrate
the stupidity of Nazis she does a good
job of grilling him for what that's
worth are you a Nazi
well for the past
fifteen 20 years I have not had anything
to do with any national socialist
organization on a formal basis but do
you call your side you'd have a ID I
don't call myself and I say I call
myself an American patriot and statesman
okay well let me give our viewers some
details about this just so they can
decide for themselves you've been part
of anti-semitic groups since the 1970s
you go to neo-nazi rallies we have
pictures of you there you are we're part
of the white people's party you dressed
in Nazi garb and you celebrate Hitler's
birthday you're a Nazi well yes I mean I
do love the one your first response I
haven't been I haven't been like a
formal Nazi for like 15 20 years okay
well done dude so I Nazis stupid and bad
thing I hate okay other things that I
hate a woman is now claiming that the
they choose force to flush her emotional
support hamster down the toilet I am not
kidding apparently an employee for
Spirit Airlines allegedly demanded a
young woman either let her pet hamster
free outside the airport or flush it
down the toilet leading her to choose
the latter which is just yuck a 21 year
old college student Florida native Belen
Alda cocea informed the Miami Herald
she'd ensured the emotional support
hamster would not be a problem by
contacting the airline prior to coming
to the airport however once she tried to
board the plane an employee for spirit
allegedly told her to get rid of the
animal as she could not board the flight
otherwise with friends and family too
far away and her age restricting her
ability to rent a car she opted to flush
the animal down the toilet which is like
what wait what now like if you have it
in a cage you couldn't just like leave
it there or find a mailing depot you
flush it you killed the animal okay so
there's that number number two an
emotional support hamster like we've
seen emotional support peacocks how
about this you know children like small
children like my children they have what
they call love ease right we're talking
about like blankies or little stuffed
animals how about that do that
what is this emotional support hamster
nonsense I can't wait for them to have
emotional support snakes just so we can
have snakes on the plane I'm really
excited about that I want somebody have
an emotional support Cobra and then we
can actually there's snakes on the MFM
plane I'm looking forward to that okay
final thing that I hate so I have to go
through this in detail because it is
astonishing ly stupid astonishingly
terrible so there is a piece that is out
at a public
called the forward the forward is a
radical left publication every so often
they asked me to write something for
them sometimes I do sometimes I do not
the publisher is pretty good about
letting opposing views appear there but
there's no question that it is a far
left no it's it's a far left publication
well they have a piece out today from a
woman named Tamara Colton she's a female
rabbi and psychologist in Birmingham
Michigan now number one when most people
say female rabbis there are some female
rabbis who are knowledgeable but most
female rabbis are in the
Reconstructionist a reform movement and
they're not very knowledgeable like is a
is a lay Orthodox Jew and not a member
of the priestly caste
not another rabbi know a lot more than
somebody like Tamara Colton just because
I read the Bible on a regular basis how
do I know I know more than she does
because my god dude but here's what she
wrote she wrote a piece basically saying
that Adam and Eve is the first case of
me - of hashtag me - and I have to
explain this because it's so insane this
execrable journey into biblical exegesis
goes so far off the rails that actually
starts running Harrison Ford down
Harrison Ford actually has to run to
avoid the engine of stupidity turning
the ground up after him he has to dive
into a ravine to avoid it and only later
does he find out that he can get rid of
his leg chains I mean it's just terrible
anyway here is Tamera Colton so she says
quote as a 47 year old woman rabbi I've
become emboldened by these brave young
women to speak a truth that I've known
in my heart for a long time but have
been hesitant to share the time has come
for me to step forward - it's time we
all acknowledge an overwhelmingly
powerful source of shame and silence in
the Bible okay now you'd expect her to
go from here to like the stop in
Leviticus about virginity until marriage
or like the stuff in Leviticus about
homosexuality or the stuff in Leviticus
about forbidden sexual relationships
mail order the stuff in Jewish tradition
about modesty right yeah that's where
you would expect her to go it would be
stupid but that's where you would expect
her to go but that's not where she goes
instead she goes to Adam and Eve now you
ask how does Adam and Eve have anything
to do with with me - oh well let rabbi
Colton tell you quote the story that
begins the Bible the first one that we
learned in Sunday school the founding
story of man and woman upheld for
thousands of years by judeo-christian
religion is actually the first is
actually the story of the first sexual
assault of a woman the woman's name is
Eve and the perpetrator is God does she
read like English or
Greek or Hebrew or any human language
okay here are a few words that describe
this stupid fatuous harebrained doltish
preposterous asinine ridiculous
ludicrous imbecilic there's just a few
words that come to mind the story of
Adam Adam has literally nothing to do
with sexual assault it has to do with
Eve disobeying a direct command from God
not to eat from a certain tree she eats
from the tree at the behest of the snake
who tells her that nothing bad will
happen and the God has been lying to her
it turns out God is not in fact lying to
her and then he says what did you do and
then she makes an excuse for it and then
he curses her with pain and childbirth
and curses Adams have to till the ground
with the sweat of his brow okay that's
the story what in the world does that
have to do with sexual assault nothing
nothing but here's what she says quote I
want you to think about this here is a
young beautiful intelligent naked woman
living in a state of grace she's hungry
so she does the most natural thing in
the world and eats a piece of fruit for
following her instincts trusting herself
and nourishing her body she is punished
her punishment she will never again feel
safe in her nakedness
she'll never again love her body she
will never again know her body as a
place of sacred sovereignty but to to
paraphrase Shakespeare what the f there
is no way to read that story and come
away with that here is the relevant
verbiage from the book of Genesis quote
for God knows that when you eat from it
your eyes will be open and you will be
like God knowing good and evil right
this is what the snake says when the
woman saw that the fruit of the tree was
good for food and pleasing to the eye
and also desirable for gaining wisdom
she took some and ate it she also gave
some to her husband who was with her and
he ate it then the eyes of both of them
were open and they realized they were
naked so they sewed fig leaves together
and made coverings for themselves you
notice anything there about like
horrific pains of hunger that she had to
be sated with only this fruit as opposed
to all the other trees in the garden
which God has said she can eat from is
there anything there about God shaming
her for her nakedness or is it that she
eats a piece of fruit realizes she's
naked and then feels ashamed because she
feels that she has misused her purpose
in the world which is what the story is
really about right none of this makes
any sense but Colton's not done she says
what have you done
God thunders Eve wants to defend herself
but she's too ashamed to speak Eve our
first mother whose name means the mother
of all living things is silence much the
way the patience of dr. Delany Nassar
were no here's the actual Bible quote
then the Lord God said to the woman what
is this you have done the woman said the
serpent deceived me and I ate
where was she silenced exactly he asked
her a question and she answered the
question but this is so I mean it's just
so stup
the story is not about men violating
women God commands Adam that commands
Eve he punishes them both he punishes
the snake the end that's the whole story
you have to be a to come up with
this with this pathetic interpretation
but I guess when you are a hammer
everything looks like a nail and when
you're a meat you hammer everything
including stories that have nothing to
do with me to look like a nail my
goodness the stupidity Wow high-level
stupidity okay time for some mail bag
let's mail bag this up alright so if you
have live questions now is the time to
ask them in daily wear chat box and no I
will not answer questions about pudding
or Michael Moses evening attire just
horrifying okay Lowell says I feel
modern libertarianism is gaining
popularity after seeing Gary Johnson's
gain from the 2012 to 2016 elections and
when I feel is a growing popularity from
Rand Paul libertarian leanings why in
your opinion is the Libertarian Party
not prominence in the government today
because they suck at everything as the
answer okay the libertarian party
convention was a crap show it was a guy
running out naked with an iron cross
there's a bunch of people like John
McAfee talking about legalizing acid
okay that's not what you'll lead with if
you're the libertarians if you're the
libertarians why you go get some decent
candidates who can talk in conservative
slash libertarian tones about the
necessity for small government and how
that leads to freedom why is it that I'm
better representative of libertarian
than Gary Johnson why is it that I'm a
better representative liberal of
libertarianism than anyone who's on the
stage at the libertarian party
convention it makes you think that the
libertarian party is actually a giant
scam to get you to give them lots of
money and then not earn enough of the
vote to actually be put under severe
government scrutiny because my goodness
how else could you explain the supreme
incompetence at every level of the
libertarian party plus again they've
elevated members of the libertarian
party who are soft defense libertarians
which is not smart and people who say
that are sort of almost
anarcho-capitalists to the top levels of
the libertarian party well that is a
that is not an electoral position for
victory now that says hi Ben I'm a
Christian but I don't believe in
original sin I have to pay for what Adam
did wrong what is the Jewish Vilnius so
the Jewish view is that original sin is
not about you have a sin that must be
relieved by God's grace that is imbued
in you because of original sin there is
no concept of original sin in Judaism in
that sense what original sin is is that
Adam committed the sin of disobeying God
and this led us to I think there are a
few interpretations obviously of this
story but I think that the one that I
like the best
is the interpretation that essentially
says that before man ate from the tree
of knowledge
there was a full identity between what
things were for and what they were
meaning that just as in the Aristotelian
notion if a watch is is made for telling
time then man was made to do certain
things and fruit worm was made to
fulfill certain needs and animals were
made to fulfill certain tasks right
everything was made for its purpose and
we could see that but we didn't
necessarily have our own logic as to
morality right God's morality was our
morality
once we supplanted our morality for
God's morality that led us to an
inordinate number of conflicts that
prevented us in any real sense from
seeing paradise because the world around
us started to look malevolent as opposed
to looking like what it was the world is
just the world and the world fulfills a
purpose that is not our own right the
world that fills a purpose that is God's
the idea of original sin that has to be
expiated I don't think that's right the
the Judaism doesn't it does right you do
some things that human beings are human
beings and that the capacity for sin is
comes along with the capacity for
freewill and that that cannot be
expiated by the sacrifice of another
person or a person in the form of God
that that's not a thing sacrifices that
you bring in Jewish tradition are to
expiate your own personal sin not to
expiate sins of the past Kevin says with
all of the bombshells about the FBI and
at DoD at Obama's DOJ coming bout well
Hillary Clinton finally be indicted or
has the time passed a bit jaded with our
government I seriously doubt she'll be
indicted I seriously doubt she'll be
indicted as well number one you'd have
to have such strong evidence to indict
her at this point after the FBI
basically cleared her last year that I
think that the impetus for inciting her
would be would be pretty weak I also
think that even if there's a political
argument and an argument from a country
basis then inciting her might not be the
smartest move just because I could see
this really quickly leading to a
situation where whoever runs in an
election and loses gets indicted by the
other side as sort of Banana Republic
stuff even though everyone should be
held accountable to the law and I think
Hillary should have been indicted last
year I think that now it looks more to
the public like a revenge play by
Trump's DOJ or FBI then it would look
like a real investigation I mean nobody
trusts the DOJ and the FBI on the right
nobody trusts the DOJ and the FBI on the
left I'm not sure this would restore
that trust
Ricky says hey Ben my listen you speak
about the memo released and how your
major qualms with that is the idea it
shows a target of Donald Trump you don't
agree necessarily shows that the
question I
than is this how does it dossier that is
almost exclusively about tunneled from
justify a warrant against Carter page
unless the thing they're investigating
page four is related to Donald Trump
well we haven't actually seen the FISA
application according to the reports of
the FISA application they're not really
about Trump the stuff that Papadopoulos
might be so it's possible that some of
it involves Trump Russia collusion and
they think Carter page is a part of that
because he was part of the Trump
campaign but the stuff in the steel
dossier is not just about Trump right I
mean it is about Trump Russia campaign
collusion but the stuff that was
specifically referencing Carter page
also had to do with Carter page making
specific outreach moved toward the
Russian government so if it was entirely
about Trump then you could say that the
FISA warrant was I guess targeting Trump
in ancillary fashion but let me let me
let me backtrack for just a second if
the question is was the FBI only
targeting Trump what the carter page
warrant the answer is maybe
but the investigation started before
carter page so it's actually two
separate questions you can believe that
the FBI was was targeting Trump with the
Carter page warrant the question is was
that legit or not or was the Carter page
weren't trumped up in order to get Trump
and the answer is not supremely clear if
there was independent evidence to go
after Trump
anyway and this was just part of that
general investigation as opposed to
Carter page initiated the investigation
and that's the only evidence that we
have that Trump did anything wrong so if
I if I made the implication that the FBI
was quote-unquote not out to get Trump
at all or that they thought Trump was
not involved at all I don't think that
the FBI thought Trump was not out that
Trump was not involved at all the FBI
probably did think that Trump was
involved in some way but out to get
Trump and thinks Trump involved is
involved in some way are two separate
contentions it's two separate
contentions okay so let's see Joseph
says hey mr. Shapiro having listened to
your discussion a few weeks ago with Sam
Harris it brought to my attention that
some atheists believe there's no such
thing as free will can you in a simple
words as possible explain this to me am
i incorrect they believe they're just
balls of meat floating through the
cosmos and that everything supposedly
happens due to random chance I may be
off wouldn't those circumstances be
essentially the epitome of free will
okay so there's two ways to read free
well there is the but for choice that
you actually have the capacity to make a
choice this is how people traditionally
thought of free well I can choose right
now to say the next sentence I can
choose not to say the next
is up to me it's not determined by my
environment it's not determined by by
genetics that I do have but for free
well we don't understand how it works
but that's the way that it works right
that you do control your own action you
have the capacity for change then there
is the version of free will that is
essentially passive free well suggesting
that random chance governs human
behavior and that there's no way to
fully predictably say what exactly
you're gonna do next right I think that
sam Harris's version of free will which
isn't really free will at all as he is
correct as he correctly points out it's
just suggesting that random chance has a
role in what we say and what we do but
if you can't control that random chance
then it's not freewill
right there the words free and will
neither of them apply you're talking
about random chance governing that is
the significant difference and so the
question for me is how can you propose
that human beings be active in the
universe when activity is formally
banned by your definition of free well
Isaac says what is your patient opinion
on the house of Israel are they forever
removed from the Covenant or will God
someday bring them back in well I'm
Jewish so I don't think that they were
ever removed from the Covenant right in
the Christian viewpoint you have to ask
drew and Michael because they're
Christian what they what they think of
the house of Israel and where it stands
in the Covenant but from the Jewish
perspective we are still the covenant
and that covenant is it was never broken
that so end of story that Ryan says hey
man I'm currently in grad school in New
York to be a teacher so is there a lot
of conversation about racism toward
people of color I recall you saying on
one of your shows Jewish people became
white as soon as we became successful
can you give me some examples of
discrimination against Jewish people in
American history sure the Harvard Law
School for a long time had quotas on
Jewish students at the law school
country clubs around the country used to
ban Jews there restaurants that ban Jews
there were housing projects that banned
Jews there were there stores that banned
Jews there's an entire movie about this
called gentlemen's agreements about
hotels that ban Jews with Gregory Peck I
mean won Best Picture in 1948 so you can
check that out as well my house has been
who is your favorite singer of all time
well opera singer Pavarotti non opera
singer you have to go with Sinatra for
his phrasing although I do have a
sneaking fondness for Mel Torme now
Patrick says hey Ben I recently went to
a facility that give me the to give
plasma and was able to get paid for my
contribution if you can call it that
that got me thinking what would be the
ethical implications of offering to sell
parts of our own bodies should an organ
be able to be sold if the owner is
willing to take money for it what would
be the impact on the organ donation
system so I
always been in favor of an Oregon market
I'm in favor of the idea that you should
be able to sell your kidney or a
cellular or cell a lobe of your liver if
they can do a liver transplant that the
there'd have to be some stringent
regulations about like you're not
allowed to kill yourself for the money
you're not allowed to kill a family
member for the money there'd have to be
some actual stringent regulations with
regard to this but it seems to me it is
a much better solution to the organ
shortage then attempting to determine if
somebody is dead or not and then
harvesting their organs now I know says
you spoke of your favorite sci-fi books
what are your top three sci-fi movies so
I actually named these the other day I'm
trying to remember what I said about it
so I'm not gonna count fantasy in my
sci-fi rankings here and I'm not gonna
give you three I'm gonna give you a
bunch okay because there there are a lot
of sci-fi movies that I love so
obviously Star Wars is up there all
boats slash fantasy probably in just in
terms of pure sci-fi I think Blade
Runner 2049 was really good this year I
thought that it was top-notch
I liked interstellar a lot I liked a lot
of these are modern films Planet of the
Apes is the oldest sci-fi film that's
really good plan of the ages terrific
the original with Charlton Heston let's
see the was the one I what's the one Tom
Cruise edge of tomorrow thank you the
worst title in human history where they
had actually retitled didn't really set
his live repeat die because that was a
live die repeat well is what it was and
so so and then in case that that's a
very very good sci-fi movie there been a
bunch of them recently I thought arrival
was quite good they're a Close
Encounters of the Third Kind I'll have
to make a complete list and put it up on
Twitter but they're a bunch of them et
is a really good movie yeah I love
sci-fi and I love sci-fi flicks Tommy
says Ben how important do you think it
is for all Americans to read the memos
everyone seems to have an opinion but
few seams of Reddit is this folly
yes everyone should read the memos and
please if you want to solve the question
as to whether the FBI was explicitly
targeting Trump with the Carter phage
the Carter page FISA warrant again by
the way quick note on what I said before
about the the page warrant I think it's
worthwhile noting that none of that
stuff leaked until after the election
and also it is worth noting that when it
comes to the Carter page FISA warrant
that the application
for the warrant still has not made been
puttan didn't made public by President
Trump who can do it right now we can
declassify it right now I wish he would
so that we can find out what exactly was
in it and what exactly wasn't in it
mark says hi Ben if you had complete
control of the process how would you fix
Social Security I would privatize the
entire thing I'd say to people it's your
money maybe you have make it an opt-out
system where default is that a certain
amount of your money goes into a Social
Security trust fund just for you but you
actually get to opt out now what I would
do to finance the remaining Social
Security that's on the books is you
would have to presumably sell bonds and
borrow to finance Social Security but
you can have to cut up a cut-off point
now or there's not gonna be any cutoff
point later basically everyone who's
already on Social Security gets paid
what they're owed on Social Security and
when I say what their Oh Timon what
they've been promised and people who are
maybe five ten years away from Social
Security get to opt into an optional
system or not and below that we're going
to encourage you to to take your money
out and put in the stock market and
they'd says why can't the Democrats
point to something that Trump actually
did as an example of the alleged
collusion or as collusion just a
meaningless term at this point it's a
meaningless term at this point it means
anything that they don't like that there
there are a couple things here that are
problematic george papadapolis going to
london and soliciting information from a
Russian source about Hillary Clinton
emails and the Donald Trump jr. meeting
at Trump Tower those are the two big
ones other than that I have seen no I've
seen no evidence of Russian collusion
whatsoever at this point okay Jim says
with all this talk of Russia Russia
Russia could you please explain these
areas in which US Russian interests
coincide and come into conflict
well the real answer is Russia sometimes
once you take out Islamic regimes that
threaten them sometimes Russia wants to
crack down on Islamic radicals in
Chechnya for example but aside from that
we do not have a lot of cons coinciding
interests with the Russian regime it is
a an incredibly self-interested regime
it is a regime that is interested in
maximization of Vladimir Putin's
personal power so there there's not a
lot of crossover there other than
maintaining a status of non nuclear war
I would think gabe's has been I'm in law
school and leave every class in despair
because the Supreme Court seems to have
trampled the Constitution had every
available opportunity at least since the
1930s should we as conservatives and
originalist
be worried that we are past the point of
no return when it comes to judicial
review and the super legislative
function of the courts yes I mean we
should have been worried about that back
in the
30s which is why as I have stated
repeatedly I've been trying to hold to
this paper for years
I wonder if Harvard actually has it I
have to call them up I wrote my third
year law paper on why judicial review
should essentially be undone the idea
that judiciary gets to overrule the
legislature on behalf of an Oleg our key
of those chosen not elected seems
supremely anti-republican to me Nate
says hey Ben I'm a Christian I attend
and one of the topics that the world
beats Christians up on so much his
evolution pretended Li toured the ISM on
this topic I think God can be the
creator and evolution can still exist
where do you stand on this issue of
course I think that that's the case I
think that God can use whatever natural
mechanism he chooses and God tries to in
order for God to assume your faith he's
not going to show you miracles every day
unless you're looking for them when
unless you see miracles in the natural
world and in the system of God's laws in
fact Newton was more likely to see
miracles in the systematization of the
universe than he was to see miracles in
you know the splitting of the Red Sea I
think that God can use whatever
mechanism he chooses in order to in
order to forward the possibilities of
humanity and that's what he did with
evolution in my opinion there's a great
book called God in the Big Bang and by a
Gerard wives were escaping me today
Gerald Schroeder journal Schroeder I can
check that out it's all about the the
consonants between the Bible and
evolutionary theory and the theories of
the Big Bang really fascinating stuff
okay so we've reached the end of today's
nearly endless mailbag we'll be back
here on Monday to discuss all of the
latest have a wonderful weekend please
don't ruin things or there will be no
Disneyland for you I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Mathis Plummer executive producer Jeremy
boring senior producer Jonathan hey our
technical producer is austin stevens
edited by alex and Garo audio is mixed
by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is by
Joshua Oliveira the Ben Shapiro show is
a daily wire for word publishing
production copyright for publishing 2018